heute gibt es hühnerfrikassee das
gericht was ich als kind geliebt habe
wir machen das auf die einfache und
schnelle art und ich wette mit euch dass
wir die jeder in der familie lieben also
kommt damit
[Musik]
zum hühnerfrikassee gehört immer reis
dafür habe ich den halt schon
vorbereitet einfach dem was marty reis
richtig schön ausspülen damit wir die
stärke wegspielen ich persönlich mag es
nicht so klebrig die stärke sorgt
nämlich dafür dass es halt so ein
bisschen klebt wer das mag kann das
einfach lassen den schritt und
anschließend in salzwasser komplett
jahren
das passiert der karte nebenbei und ich
mache jetzt weiter mit meiner
hähnchenbrust die werde ich jetzt in
mundgerechte stücke schneiden und
anschließend in etwas kokosöl anbraten
falls euch jetzt fragt warum habe ich
denn hähnchenfleisch in kokons fett
angebraten das hat einfach den grund
dass viele sich eventuell unsicher sind
wenn sie das jetzt zum beispiel in
butter anbraten ich persönlich finde
dass butter aber zu wenig dass sie auf
jeden fall dazu gehört bekommt es bei
mir gleich rein aber beim kokosfett
könnt ihr einfach auch stark erhitzen
ohne dass es euch anderen anders bei der
butter die brennen nämlich sehr schnell
an und mein kokosfett ist komplett
geschmacks und geruchsneutral daher
benutze ich das super gerne zum kochen
dann verlinke ich gerne in die infobox
genauso wie alle ganz genauen
mengenangaben so und jetzt kommen bei
mir noch frühlingszwiebeln rein und da
könnt ihr gerne auch normale zimmer
nehmen aber ich finde auch
frühlingszwiebeln eben einfach noch mal
so eine richtig schöne farbe und nachdem
ihr dann das hähnchenfleisch wirklich
nur eine minute von jeder seite
angebrachten habt sonst jetzt nämlich zu
trocken könnt ihr auch schon die
frühlingszwiebel dazu gehen und einfach
mit
gartoo er stand gerade noch in einem
anderen video hier hat sich ein
frühstück gemacht
und das werde ich ist übrigens
gewicht dir einmal die frühlingszwiebel
mit dazu noch so eine minute mit garen
und macht euch um das fleisch keine
sorgen auch wenn es nur kurz anbraten es
wird auf jeden fall gar spätestens wenn
es dann in der soße quasi zu ende gar
fast fast was gibt mir noch 810 minuten
damit ich fertig ich wünsche dir nicht
weiter reden
ja ja
ja
ich bin aus dem konzept ich habe
übrigens salz und pfeffer zum hähnchen
dazu gegeben das wollte ich euch auch
gesagt haben also gern jetzt schon mal
ein bisschen würzen gleich kommt aber
noch mehr würze mit dazu und an der
stelle gebe ich jetzt auch schon mal die
butter mit rein wie kann euch jetzt safe
nicht mehr anbrennen ich habe jetzt auch
stufe 6 von 9 butter dazu ist ein toller
geschmacksträger und damit die soße
richtig schön sämig wird geben wir jetzt
gleich auch schon ein bisschen mehl mit
dazu so
ich habe mir extra angestrengt nicht so
sozusagen
[Musik]
ich werde jetzt noch mein gemüse klein
schnibbeln ich nehme da am liebsten
möhren erbsen können mich immer dazu und
champignons das weiß der haben sondern
nicht da haben sie mal keine champignons
im
moment aber es gehört halt einfach dazu
finde ich und was auch dazugehört ist
spargel aber wir haben keine saison und
ich wollte gerne spargel aus dem glas
nehmen daher verzichte ich heute noch
mit darauf verzichte ich heute darauf
[Musik]
ich habe das gemüse jetzt hier schon zum
fleisch gegeben dass sie so schön bunt
aus und jetzt guck mal champignons sind
auch schon direkt hier mit gegart da
reicht schon die rest setze aber wir
werden das jetzt ganz das ganze jetzt
nochmal in der soße ein bisschen weniger
einkochen lassen und dafür nehmen wir
uns erstmal für den geschmack ein
spritzer zitronensaft ihr könntet auch
zum beispiel in spritze apfelessig
nehmen wenn ihr gehört kein zitronensaft
da habt und dann wird das ganze nochmal
aufgegossen mit wasser floss gemüsebrühe
pulver also gemüse brühe und sahne und
dann einfach nur noch 5 minuten köcheln
lassen und dann ist das gericht auch
schon fertig
[Musik]
lass es dir schmecken und soll ruhig
ehrlich ich hab ihn afrikas seeger
machen heute schon war kein scherz ja
ich habe die chance ist da rausgeholt
du weißt ich mag das nicht so sehe ich
das gerne dazu das kind auch nach meinem
geschmack da
wir bei kosten möglich auch immer mehr
stämme von dem
haben sich viele leute jobs geschaffen
übrigens bei uns immer so ich es so reiß
speisen eigentlich auch noch mit dem
löffel wie haben sie aber für die kamera
bis märz mitgeteilt
ich bin ich gut
und mir auch gefallen kein shopping uns
wirklich geholt ich liebe südafrika
steht das ist mein gott was mach ich das
übrigens das erste rezept dass ich quasi
gemacht habe als ich ein kind war was
aber wenig verändert in der friteuse
bisschen sammeln ein bisschen sagen ja
der mainzer anteil macht gemüsebrühe
außen wenig zutaten und heute richtig
lecker
auf jeden fall besser zu machen also ich
kenne das ja schon von der außer
champignons deswegen bin ich jetzt nicht
auf aber nicht mehr einfach gut also
gehe ich ganz ehrlich bevor ich jetzt
hier
doch eine komme mehr für mich ganz
wichtig das ist du machst das was mich
beeindrucken und machtlos sein es muss
das originalrezept seien
aber ist führt das üblicherweise
geschaffen
ich persönlich finde immer mit champions
und aber mal mit spargel wie seht ihr
das habt ihr vielleicht so eine sportart
aber schaffen ja ich finde also ich
wünsche mir uns müssen sondern schon für
den geschmack und wenn ihr gar keine
chance vertan weglassen wenn ihr sowie
haben so seid einfach so sagt ich kann
mir das jetzt am esstisch wünsche euch
viel spaß beim nachkochen und wenn man
sagt
ja
es gibt sie
[Musik]